if we had hired a 25 year old  man  who was  not ugly  well you best believe that i would eat  the sh  out of his butthole  this is exactly why  so many female comedians are frankly  really really terrible it's because  they're so impressed with their own  vulgarity  it's like she was getting ready maybe to  say something funny and poignant but at  the very last moment  right on the cusp of almost saying  something clever and witty  she veered right into a butthole and uh  which is not where you want to be  and that's the problem with with almost  all feminist comedy i know exactly where  it's going  and most of the time  it's going into the pants somewhere